welcome to the new era of
service delivery covid19 digital
transformation
welcome everyone and thank you for
attending our session i hope everyone
has been doing well in these difficult
times
today we'll be discussing how the kova
19 pandemic has caused government
agencies to digitally transform in how
they deliver critical
public health and benefit program
services leveraging google cloud
my name is chris haas and i'm a
strategic business executive with google
cloud
focusing on our public health response
solutions brandon
hi i'm brandon williams i'm the
innovation strategy manager in eagle
county colorado
and i break things and sometimes even
fix them
great the copa 19 pandemic is impacting
communities
all over the world at the same time it
has inspired coordination between public
and private sectors and across
international borders on a remarkable
scale the best way for technology
companies like google to help
is by supporting the work of public
health authorities
to keep people healthy and safe the full
impact of cover 19 is still unfolding
however there are already major changes
in the government and the use of
technology and aiding pandemic response
efforts
google is proud to be one of many
organizations partnering with government
agencies during this period
we are working alongside government
leaders to implement new solutions that
help them to enable remote workforce to
continue to operate normally during the
pandemic
enable them to leverage real-time and
historical data for pandemic
policy decision making and support them
for what's coming next
as our country reopens and the economy
jump starts
including planning for future phases of
the pandemic
the developing silver lining is how this
these paradigm shifts are affecting
change in how governments deliver
digital services
both now and beyond the pandemic
google is helping governments in a few
major areas
aiding agencies to handle the rapid
surge by providing scalable systems and
virtual assistance
enabling rapid application development
and deployment of modern systems to
manage the pandemic benefit programs
and implementation can happen within
days and weeks versus months and years
also leveraging ai and ml for processing
documents to help automate the massive
amounts of paper being submitted
to agencies our differentiator is our
speed and agility
to help agencies bring new
cost-effective solutions online
enabling states to more effectively
manage constituent applications
i feel there's one standout theme in our
how our country is managing this
pandemic
it's the speed of our response efforts
local governments are needing to break
down traditional processes
and modernize legacy systems to ensure
they are moving as quickly as possible
to respond to the rapidly expanding
needs of our constituents
there is an expectation of government to
operate as normal
even in these abnormal times the vision
for
our public health response platform is
to transform the ability
of public health officials to detect
evaluate
react to and manage risks posed to
public health and safety by the pandemic
we strive to offer a 10x scale
to 10x scale public health officials
ability
to gain situational awareness across
their entire environment
and to effectively engage and educate
the public at multiple levels
whether it be a specific individual in
contact racing efforts
and or to the public at large
public health authorities have an
incredibly important role in responding
to kova 19
but they face many challenges due to the
scale of the pandemic
in addition to organizational
limitations caused by legacy processes
and systems
which slow their response efforts
there's a flood of new data but limited
ability to understand it for decision
making
if they are even able to access and
leverage it at all due to regulatory
and or privacy concerns and their
operating environment
is constantly changing resulting in
incorrect or misinformation
but there are many opportunities for
innovation by leveraging google cloud
serverless
analytics and ai ml technology
government agencies are scaling their
limited human resources through
automation and reducing manual tasks
to identify and trace new cases predict
the spread of the virus and effectively
engage and educate the public
on the response efforts and real time
information
we need to remember that data
warehousing is not a use case
data warehouse is a solution that
enables higher order use cases to make
organizations data driven
organizations have started using data
warehouses as the foundation for
operational reporting
for example monthly standardized reports
government organizations must
increasingly enable their teams to carry
out
ad hoc analyses this requires the use of
self-service tools
organizations are also looking to mine
the right data
stored in their data warehouses to
perform ad hoc analysis to understand
correlations
identify patterns and detect anomalies
as
organizations increasingly aspire to be
data driven they are trying to harness
the rich data in their data warehouse to
create predictive analytic
models and operationalize these
predictive insights
this requires the data warehouse to
support their machine learning
initiatives
our goal is to help government transform
into operationalized decision-making
organizations
but the typical deros project is fraught
with failure and millions of dollars of
wasted money
traditional platforms are just not
capable of keeping up with the new
demands
we have on interconnected data needs at
google we are uniquely positioned to
support organizations in migrating to
new data analytics
platform technologies why because we
used to have the same problems many
enterprises now face
we solve the data pipeline
inefficiencies and complexities
with a petabyte scale data warehouse
platform called
google cloud bigquery we offer the same
analytics technology to all enterprises
now with simple pricing
bigquery is fully managed in serverless
which means there is no infrastructure
to manage
you can simply focus on analyzing your
data to find meaningful insights
using familiar sql queries
and through our serverless data
analytics solution we eliminate the need
for systems engineering
in the data analytics workflow so that
you can focus 100 of your time
on data analysis
governments realize this innovation by
digitally transforming through their use
of the google public health response
platform
working closely with our partners google
has built a serverless analytics and
application modernization platform
which aids public health across major
pandemic response areas
such as disease and case management
including active and passive contact
racing
which is a critical aspect of public
health pandemic response
also tracking of resources and logistics
and engaging the community through
proactive outreach and education
at the center of google's smart
analytics platform enabling government
agencies to leverage their data in new
ways to accelerate
innovation and deliver critical services
integrating public health response
solutions with google's smart analytics
platform
enables customers to easily scale the
processing
and analysis of data our fully managed
serverless approach
automatically takes care of performance
scalability and availability
requirements
for your data analysis with no
infrastructure to manage
you can easily leverage products like
bigquery to analyze gigabytes to
petabytes of data in minutes
not months public health agencies are
now driving
instant insight from their data
empowering professional
and citizen data analysts with ai
powered predictive insights
with a secure and compliant foundation
agency and constituent data is secured
and private google offers built-in data
protection at scale
to help protect governments from
intrusion theft and attacks
our multi-layered security approach
across hardware services
user identity storage internet
communication and operations
provides redundancy and reliability
while our purpose-built chips
servers storage network and data centers
protect against hardware level intrusion
data is automatically encrypted while in
transit and at rest
and can only be accessed by the
authorized roles and services defined by
the customer
with audited access to the encryption
keys within google cloud
data is also automatically replicated
and encrypted for backup and disaster
recovery
and at a basic level in public health we
can't even begin to have a conversation
without talking about security and
compliance
so compliance such as fedramp high trust
and hipaa certifications
amongst others are built into the core
of all of our products
no matter where you are on the journey
to digital transformation know that we
have the capabilities to help you solve
your mission outcome
using maturity frameworks such as this
we will help you assess your
organization's maturity
and serve as your trusted advisor
identifying the appropriate capabilities
and use cases you should be focusing on
so let's
talk through an example leveraging
serverless and ai powered
contact center and chatbot solutions our
contact center ai or ccai
and dialogflow solutions are rapidly
deployable and able to integrate with
public health contact tracing processes
to automate the human tracer activities
and reduce
manual case management tasks whether
that be engaging with people via the
phone
or online chat leveraging ccai
government agencies can transform their
contact center into an ai powered
customer-centric optimization platform
which integrates all valuable data
provides real-time and relevant
information to callers and agents
and turns customer interactions into
actionable insights
here we have an example video let's
watch for a moment
first we have a phone call with a person
which the public health agency would
like to
engage with for contact tracing
powered by contact center ai and dialog
flow
the virtual agent is able to interact
with the caller to collect
some of the needed contact tracing
details
let's have a listen
hi this is the department of health as
part of an investigation into a
confirmed case of covid19
we are following up with individuals who
may have had contact with a case while
they were possibly contagious
we are calling to check on you and
discuss some public health
recommendations
is it okay to go ahead yes
thank you we'll start with your name
please tell me your first and last name
brian mcdonald
okay i have your first name is brian and
your last name is mcdonald
next i'll need you to provide your date
of birth you can say something like
january 3rd 2000 or may 15
1995. please go ahead
um january 17 2000
got it i have your date of birth as
january 17
2000 now please tell me your home
address
1951 east spring street
jacksonville i have your address as 1951
east spring street in jacksonville are
you calling in with your own phone
number
yes okay
right now we are following up with
individuals who may have been present at
john's bar
and restaurant on the 24th of may 2020
were you present at the location on that
day
i was
next the caller is transferred to a live
agent
well-being do you have any questions
yes i want to talk to a contact tracer
sure please hold while i transfer you
at this point the live agent is able to
leverage contact center ai's
agent assist technology to provide them
with live and recommended knowledge
based
responses to the caller's questions
hello brian i see you'd like to speak
with a contact tracer
how can i help you oh thank you um could
you tell me how my privacy will be
protected
that's a great question first off
we want to thank you for calling in we
take this very
seriously the confidentiality of your
identity
and health information is of the utmost
importance
your name will never be shared with
anyone who refers to
and their privacy will be protected as
well ultimately
privacy encourages participation in
adoption and as a result
will help us protect more people oh
that's great i see leveraging google
cloud's
contact center ai and dialog flow as
well as expertise in ai and ml
built into our speech text and natural
language processing solutions
we were able to automate many of the
human contact tracer tasks
additionally we are able to
automatically transform this
conversation from unstructured
to structured data for further analysis
by public health agencies
here's the high-level architecture at
each stage
collection transformation analysis and
visualization
we are using serverless technology to
deliver a modern
and scalable solution for government and
this solution provides
powerful out-of-the-box analyses and
visualizations
which enables public health responders
to take action immediately
throughout the pandemic we've been
implementing this and many other public
health
response solutions with government
customers around the world
for example the state of illinois has
deployed ccai and dialog flow in their
contact centers to aid
in their pandemic response efforts both
for contact tracing
and for benefit programs
additionally the state of new york is
done similar both of these states have
been hit hard by kova 19 and are
seeing success using these types of
solutions in responding to the pandemic
so circling back to our functional
overview and the core
google cloud smart analytics platform
let's take a quick look at the
visualization output from this platform
here's an example here
we're leveraging google's looker
dashboarding
visualization and business intelligence
tool
to bring in visualize and analyze
all of the covid19 data that we're
collecting
into the public health response platform
and remember this is a serverless
environment the back end is completely
serverless
and the front-end dashboards that we're
looking at here
are also running in a serverless
environment
first we're looking at the state of
colorado all counties
and all data year-to-date and we're
scaling it
to just the raw data population size
now we're focusing on the last two weeks
only
and we're scaling it to 100 000
cases
and we're able to drill down even
further into county level data
and we're also able to bring in many
other
public data sets available within
google's bigquery
solution including mobility weather
and other coven 19 public data sets
all of this is delivered to our
customers
through low maintenance serverless
solutions
so that you can focus on
analyzing the data to make decisions
versus maintaining the underlying
infrastructure
to deliver this type of solution as i've
said before
we use our smart analytics platform with
the core of that being
bigquery bigquery brings in
native capabilities that allow you to do
both petabyte scale analyses in addition
to
integrated machine learning and gis
functionality
and it is a truly serverless platform
that allows you to focus
solely on your analytical needs
additionally
for application modernization you can
leverage
anthous which is our application
modernization
infrastructure that can be used in a
multi-cloud environment to deliver
these type of capabilities so with that
i'd like to hand it over to brandon
we'll take it from here thanks chris
yeah you know i think you nailed it in
talking about the need
for government or public sector
employees to be able to do complex
analysis
using simple tools natural language um
you know we started it on the arc at the
very lowest level
when kovid start first started spreading
we are a
international ski destination and you
can bet if somebody sneezes anywhere in
the world we're probably going to see it
here at some point
covid was no different we saw it pretty
early on now the complexity here was we
had limited testing despite what was
being said
the test volume was very very limited we
knew we had community spread
and we knew because recovery planning
starts when
an incident starts we knew we were going
to have to build trust
and in a pandemic the public
is just as much a team player as anybody
sitting on
the first responder or emergency
operations centers they may serve in
different capacities but we knew that
trust and data sharing was going to be
key to being able to get
through this so the first thing we did
was very simple we used a google form
and we sat down with our epi teams and
we got it out the door and this was
really just tracking symptoms where we
couldn't do testing we wanted to know
who was sick and who was not feeling
well
so we made it mobile friendly google
forms dumped into a sheet
and we were able to tie it to data
studio
the data studio allowed us to take the
information regarding symptoms the stuff
outside of testing
and combine it with the stuff that we
were getting from our private medical
practitioners
and other non-profit and other partners
and start to build a 360 picture of what
our community impact was really looking
like
it was important to us early on to only
create one dashboard
we didn't create a community dashboard
and then an internet internal
operations dashboard there's one
dashboard and so we automated as much as
possible to make sure
information we were getting was going
right out the door to the public in real
time
and so from that we got a lot of
questions from other communities on how
they could replicate it
so we stood up a quick google site we
spent some time with
youtube created some templates and we
made it available
widely available to anybody that wanted
it and very quickly we saw it adopted
across counties in colorado and
nationwide
now that turned into you know thankfully
we've got a really close working
relationship with the state of colorado
anyway they've been a long time google
partner as we have
and so being able to share data in
google was natural
and this spread up to the governor's
office
and across to the departments to be able
to figure out how could we do symptoms
tracking
and share the information back to locals
in a very narrow sense
so that it was secure real-time
information for tactical
level uh at the local level so that they
could maneuver resources and respond
but give the state that strategic
overview and picture that they needed to
be able to start allocating and thinking
uh next steps in the response
and so uh we worked together with the
state and a lot of other partners and
we were very happy to be able to launch
the same kind of symptom tracker we did
in eagle county
at the state level to start to get that
360 picture
and that's turned into a much wider
discussion about
how we share data across the disease
prevention and disease monitoring
spectrum
and so specifically it's created kind of
a new normal of data sharing
we're starting to look at that tactical
and strategic levels
being able to dump information into
central locations so that we can throw
bigquery at it
and extract the data in natural language
that's unique to a geography or a
demographic need
and be able to share that information
securely across a vast number of
partners
uh you know but it hasn't been just
google forms and sheets and data studio
we've seen an explosion in all of the
office productivity tool set
you know meet unsurprising we used to be
able to get together and talk
uh now we have to do it remotely and so
our data regarding meat explosion is
unsurprising
where i think it is surprising is in the
changing adoption rates that we saw
regarding groups regarding maps and
other dashboard elements
charts in in sheets and specifically
around google sites we've seen a real
explosion in stuff we would have
generated in pdf or other
reports we're now doing dynamically in
sites
and this is an example here we had a
regional response where we had our covid
testing locations
coming off of google sheets some other
data we created a mobile-friendly google
site that's simple enough for my mom to
use
and we pack it in with a map and contact
information
and that's updated in near real time
so that all of the testing information
and how to initiate that process
is immediately accessible
it's carried over into some of the
just-in-time training we've had to do
for emergency operations center you know
a pandemic brings in a lot of partners
many of whom have never stepped inside
of an emergency operations center before
and so to teach them about incident
command emergency operations what their
job functions and roles are
we stood up a google site we were able
to educate them with
simple youtube videos uh google docs
drive aids
job aids and be able to convey
information so they could be prepared
when they first stepped in to be able to
help and pitch in on the response
it's helped us look at our own internal
planning here is
our equivalent of an intranet as we move
to remote work we had about 170
different activities that now needed to
take place without a vpn
direct on any device securely so we
moved a lot of our processes to google
and now all of our internal operations
are accessible within
a single landing page that's greatly
reduced complexity and it's given us
additional visibility
into usage who's doing what what are the
needs where are we seeing surges and
being able to respond to that
accordingly
i think one of the more exciting things
and you alluded to it earlier was
dialogue flow
dialogue flow and a pandemic we've got
40 or 50 different players
everybody is going so and so deep the
information fluctuates on
on a constant basis and we needed one
way that people could natural language
search to get information that was
important to them dialog flow is a
perfect fit
in this case in the low code environment
it took us eight days from the first
time we sat around a table talking about
it
to where we had something deployed uh
was a very very quick turnaround
and now we're able to respond by still
keeping google docs where the
primary players are updating their
information in real time
we scrape that and make it available in
the chat we've expanded that beyond
covet as we're in wildfire season we're
now
addressing fire restrictions data
wildfire response information
and we're now on a path that we're going
to bring all of our government services
in
so that you can get to a point where you
can ask your fridge whether your
driver's license is up for renewal
i think this new normal has brought
together a lot of lessons
you know i'm really excited about i wish
we would have done it in an exercise
but i am really excited about the wider
inclusion steps that we've taken
horizontally and vertically across local
governments with state government
in this data sharing effort i think
keeping it simple was important
you know being able now that all of our
budgets just got obliterated
being able to track cost avoidance and
efficiencies with tools that we already
have at our fingertips
um you know our staff has been on google
for i think eight years now
and so these were tools that they
naturally stepped into immediately
deployed
and most importantly the tools like that
google form for symptoms tracking
we deployed that within those initial
first hours and those were designed
by you know myself and the lead of the
epi team sat down and hammered it out
so there was no delay in waiting for
communications or other designers to
step in
we designed it we deployed it and so i
think that's really key to moving
forward
deploying and iterating being able to do
something like the chat bot in real time
where information is changing so
often and keeping that updated with a
lot of partners has been
invaluable in coordinating our response
uh
here making sure the public had access
transparent accountable in real time
and being able to deliver that in in
very short order has been important
you know government sharing is just too
hard we need these recipe books a
library of customizable templates
we've seen an explosion in sharing
across
government sectors to be able to
contribute to each other to help in the
coveted response and i'm really excited
to see where that goes in the next step
i am a true believer and i do believe
government's awesome
i think the future of government work
like everybody remote work has now been
proven to be a reality
so shifting into these collaboration
tools that provide the same security
access on any device from anywhere and
being able to work
confidently remotely and do so confident
that your information is secure
has been you know pervasive in every
single program that we do
i'm really charged up about the way that
leadership has embraced this
seeing government leaders think
creatively about using these
collaboration tools
in demanding things like dashboard to
make data
data driven decisions and change and
change deployment practices sometimes
even in the middle of a response
to be able to respond to those community
needs i think is really exciting
from a collaboration standpoint this has
been unprecedented having private sector
non-profits and others sitting in that
emergency operations center and sharing
real-time information
to make sure economic recovery is
happening that community needs are being
taken care of
and that we're prioritizing cases for
testing and handling
uh has been exciting i'm looking forward
to where that takes us
in future uh future efforts when it's
not a pandemic
and i think low cost high impact you
know nothing demonstrates this
better than being able to look at the
impact that we're taking financially
from the lack of things like
travel revenue and trying to project
what that impact's going to be over the
next couple of years
and moving into that with the confidence
that we have a tool set that's going to
enable us to be able to
uh respond with the same type of
delivery that the customer expects in
their private life
and expecting government to move at the
at the speed of the private sector and
now we can do so
i think one of the things that's really
come out of this
is that need for public sector
communities to come together
and i'm so proud of the work that we're
doing with google with our partners in
the uk
with our partners at the state local and
federal level here in the united states
where we've launched a public sector
community that's building those
cookbooks those recipe books for cut
you know copy customize and deploy no
additional cost in the tools that you
already use
and that and just the conversations that
are having it bringing a face
to the common challenges that we have
and we meet on a regular basis now and
i'm looking forward to
bringing so many more members in with so
many more different ideas and eyes
thank you brandon it's always a pleasure
to partner with you
uh you're a great person to work with
the great team
that you have up there and thank you
again for presenting with me in this
session
ah thank you looking forward to it
thanks everyone